on va parler bien sûr d'alain delon
puisque tout le monde en parle
aujourd'hui les propos polémiques dans
tv mag d'alain delon est ce que tout le
monde sait qui alain delon taux de la
table d'affaires non mais ça y est même
les plus jeunes c'est bon merci voilà
très bien alors devenus grands acteurs
bien sûr qui peut me citer des films
d'alain delon le gâteau à la vanille
signé par le révéler parce qu'ils auront
parlé rafiki d'or mais le deal social
qu'est ce qu'il dit et le lien social
mélodie en sous-sol salino borsalino
revient à 900 sur l'échafaud astérix à
se faire et croquis 3 bien sûr et alain
delon il a fait des interviews dans tv
mag et il a d'abord soutenu les propos
de nadine morano qui qualifier la france
deux pays de race blanche
voilà donc bon sens voilà bon bah voilà
ça c'est alain delot sont alain delon il
aurait dit beaucoup de conneries et ils
sont des prix donc aux téléspectateurs
mais je crois que vous vous avez
exactement ce qu'il a dit gilles verdez
il a dit exactement que d'hermies y
avait des millions c'était une émission
pour des millions de con way il a
utilisé le terme qu'on a wii 2 l'on a
utilisé le terme combes ce que ça arrive
parce que ça rime
mais franchement ce qu'il a fait c'est
indigne et moi si nous écoutent alain
delon il nous regarde pas ce qu'il y'a
pas que seulement la radio si nous
regarde moi je voudrais lui parler alain
delon je crois qu'il n'a pas envie de
vous parler hein mais moi j'ai quelque
chose à lui dire alors il est là
regardez déjà ya des balles un delon non
mais c'est pas lui la halle à lui lui
c'est pas la dolomie chez bruce willis
ou ça n'a rien à voir
c'est bruce willis alors on va rappeler
on va rappeler ce qu'il a dit là des
cyril hanouna à chaque fois que je tombe
sur lui c'est toujours la même mimiques
le même sourire le même regard ce que
allah de lampard dans tous les jours ils
changent de te tais quoi en fait mais le
gars c'est vrai que genre il voit
quelqu'un on va s'en dire oui madame
d'un société il faut faire des nouvelles
têtes et quoi en fait et il a dit ce qui
me fascine salmon c'est que ces
émissions sont fait parce qu'on est sûrs
d'accrocher des millions de convois que
vous dire je vais retenir qu'une chose
c'est qu'alain delon nous regardent et
ça c'est quand même fort franchement
rixe à alain delon qui nous regardent
franchement qui me regardent ou pas son
problème mais il faut faire attention à
ce qu'il dit quand même s'il soutient
mme nadine morano c'est c'est quelque
chose acquiesce il dit que c'est qu'une
race blanche
en france faut pas oublier que nous
avons aussi des îles françaises
et il ya des noirs sur ces îles donc un
moment faut arrêter ces canaux mais je
ne viens pas besoin de dire qu'il ya des
îles pour dire qu'il faut c'est comme fo
le précis à voir si pour lui sur
l'hexagone c'est que des mythiques des
conneries ne va pas revenir là dessus
oui
non mais il a insulté les millions de
gens qui regardent cette émission alors
de longs toi là
les legs sex-symbol moi je vais dire si
ton a dans le pantalon de l'on vient ici
leur parler à ses millions
mais tu viendras pas de l'eau tu
viendras pas parce que t'as jamais rien
eu dans le pantalon et dollon ça rime
avec poltron
non
et la lie à la donne on est chez lui
fait alain delon ne viendra pas à la
dôle on n'est pas un poltron alain delon
s'en fiche oui c'est quand même le clash
le plus triste que j'ai jamais vue de ma
vie sur ma mini sar j aurais pas cru en
moi je m'en fous qui n'aiment pas les
missions qui nous critiquent qui me
critiquent ça me dérange pas du tout
mais c'est vrai qu'il a traité les
téléspectateurs voilà de quoi on voit là
ils sont les prix aussi et surtout
incohérent parce que moi j'ai lu tout
toute l'interview est vraiment lui
demande si il est proche du front
national et y répond et ça c'est
vraiment c'est beau et dit non et s'il
était pourquoi dans n'aurais-je pas le
droit
le front national représente quand même
6 millions de personnes c'est 6 millions
de comptes ont le droit de ne pas aimer
me on a le droit de respecter alors
c'est bien mais s'ils doivent pas
exactement respecter les gens qui votent
front national donc ça veut dire que les
gens qui regardent l'émission on
respecte certains qu'on est pas des
autres ces quads moins cohérent
là aussi pas été super sympa avec
anne-claire coudray en fait qu'il aime
bien il aime bien il a dit qu'il aimait
bien laurent ruquier marc olivier fogiel
claire chazal et il est bien la télé
voilà way a déjoué marco c'est vrai
qu'on aime beaucoup fouleront aussi
mesdames l'acquérir il n'aime pas quand
ça bouge
il est traître a dit voilà c'est ça
changement voilà ces impacts quand ça
bouge c'est lui aussi bouge pas beaucoup
alors oui ça fait bouger beaucoup c'est
surtout que donc s'il peut pas vous
aimez parce que chez nous ça bouge un
peu quand même hein mais si ça en fait
ils aiment bien les trucs voila voila
merci vous ça va ah oui mais très bas
mais je bouge boit ses paroles et les
vôtres aussi par la même occasion
certainement il ya certaines personnes
avait 10 ans quand là qu'ils ont une
certaine nostalgie du passé de laisser
sa rivale qui ne veut plus bouger dès
qu'on bouge quelque chose ça les
perturbe ils mangent plus la soupe la
même heure et du coup ils sont gênés et
blessés d'après alain delon pour que
vous lui parlez à oui c'est vrai ah oui
j'ai une bonne nouvelle on a le numéro
dallas de loin on l'appelle ou pas
volontiers aller on appelle tout de
suite alain delon c'est parti on sait
plus trop si je savais qu'on allait
appeler alain delon à jour ça serait
bien qu'on essaie de danger d un dîner
comme pour mathieu aussi - là alors
normalement on a une chance sur deux
pour que ce soit le bon sinon on va
tomber sur patrick bouchard alors
ouverte aux horaires
alors alors à la deûle ou alors alain
delon alain delon monsieur delon bon si
je reconnais votre voie sur deux dans
bonjour c'est l'émission touche pas à
mon poste
une idée mais je reconnais pas les faits
non ce n'est pas lui mais si cet homme
est bon très bien il veut pas vous
parler bien fort très salon il ya un mec
qui hurle autant j'aurais peur aussi